each year 40 million students graduate
high school and make what many consider
the most important decision of one's
entire life
where to attend college
anxious about their future pressured by
their parents and armed with only the
most basic understanding of compound
interest would-be college freshman make
the kind of customer most businesses
only dream of
an 18 year old is more informed about
the brand of shoes they wear than the
institution at which they'll spend 200
weeks of their lives and 84 000
on average
it's not their fault
the basic problem is information
asymmetry
prospective students can take tours
deciding whether a school's trees are a
satisfactory shade of green and
buildings sufficiently old looking but
nearly everything else they know comes
from just one source
the seller
now imagine making this decision seven
thousand miles away having never stepped
foot in the country and as a non-native
english speaker
that's the challenge faced by america's
340 000 chinese international students
so what does a diligent young adult do
to compensate
they turn to the consumer reports of
education college rankings
but for this prudence little do they
know they're rewarded with a mix of
fraud and deception
it's not just that rankings are
inaccurate or misleading
though make no mistake they are
the real problem is much much deeper
in fact almost everything wrong with
higher education today the student loan
crisis inequitable admissions academic
plagiarism and the collapse of tenure
are ultimately symptoms
symptoms of one giant interconnected web
of deceit
sponsored by fabulous the app that uses
behavioral science to help you build
healthy habits like meditation exercise
and better sleep
from the day a baby is born in china he
or she unknowingly enters a race
although they won't take the gao cow
china's college entrance exam for
another 18 years it alone will
ultimately determine their career and
social class
and determine means determine
there are no letters of recommendation
extracurriculars awards or alternate
pathways the gao cow is the only race
that matters
because it's held just once a year and
the results highly publicized the cost
of failure is enormous
every hour of sleep lost every hobby for
gone and talent abandoned is easily
justified it could be the difference
between one's dream and fall back
why do chinese students collectively
sacrifice what the rest of the world
calls adolescence for a single exam
in a word fairness
the poor farmer's daughter and chief
executive's son take the same exam in
the same room at the same time
of course in the real world the rich and
powerful usually find a way
contradictions after all have never
stopped china a communist country with
the second highest concentration of
billionaires
for middle and upper class kids an
overseas education is a lifeboat on the
titanic an escape from academic pressure
and the public spotlight respectively
hong kong chief executive carrie lamb's
son and chairman xi jinping's daughter
both attended harvard
now hold that thought for a moment
seven in ten americans attend a public
college
but despite coughing up over 21 000 us
dollars a year for in-state tuition room
and board on average students themselves
only directly contribute one-fifth of
their school's budget
most of the total about 40 percent is
covered by state federal and a bit of
local government grants contracts and
appropriations
what this means is that public
universities are largely at the whim of
their federal and state governments who
in turn depend on a healthy stream of
tax revenue
during normal times which is to say a
long time ago this was no big deal
the system imperfect as it was chugged
along mostly fine enough until the 2008
recession when schools were painfully
reminded of the house of cards they're
built upon
people lost their jobs the government
lost its tax revenue and thus
universities lost their funding
oops
not only was there just less money going
around but because there was less money
going around universities were under
greater scrutiny to use it well
less money yet more demands
so what did they do
what every good capitalist does of
course they commodified education
casting their line further and further
afield in search of untapped markets
they both exported the product slapping
their logos on deep pocketed modular
architecture everywhere and imported
customers
international students want some new
invention but universities were shocked
by how deep the wells were particularly
in china
it all began as a short-term solution to
an acute problem
fill a hole in the budget but they soon
realized the potential
the intense pressure of the gao cow
combined with china's growing middle
class had produced an insatiable desire
for overseas credentials
today there are two and a half times as
many chinese international students in
the u.s as second place india which is
itself 2.7 times larger than third place
korea
and that's not just because china is
huge the country is home to 18 percent
of the world's population but 35 of
international students in america
demand in other words had accidentally
discovered a huge underexploited supply
there was basically no limit to the
number of keen chinese students they
could attract
even a decent state school in the middle
of nowhere could arbitrage the american
brand converting its u.s address plus
the vague notion of international
exposure into cold hard cash
but say you're a chinese student who's
never stepped foot in the states
how do you pick a school despite knowing
next to nothing about the country much
less any individual city or state you
take out your phone google best colleges
in america and tap on the first result
duh
enter college rankings
students and their parents are
universally desperate for objective
answers
guidance and making the quote right
choice and later assurance that they
indeed have
rankings prey on this anxiety and doubly
so in the case of international students
whose vacuum of knowledge is ripe for
exploitation
chinese international students in
particular are both by far the largest
kind and according to this survey the
most persuaded by reputation and
prestige
the only little problem is that rankings
are
well complete and utter garbage
let's start with a low-hanging fruit it
isn't possible to reduce an entire
university to a single number at least
not without losing all meaning in the
process
in what world does goshen college a
mennonite school with 827 students in
rural indiana belong on the same list as
a party school like say the university
of alabama whose student population is
larger than the entire town of goshen
in fairness they do share the same basic
mission the proliferation of knowledge
but the same can't be said of all
schools
the mennonites look like close relatives
of crimson tide when compared to peking
university whose charter replaced
freedom of thought with loyalty to the
communist party in 2019
one building strives to cultivate the
next generation of thinkers the other to
churn out obedient workers
yet the big three international rankings
qs arwoo and the times don't even
acknowledge the fact that entire fields
of study are forbidden at some
universities
but okay enough with all the high-minded
philosophy
at the end of the day people like to
rank things and there is an undeniable
difference between your local community
college and mit
assuming that schools can be reduced to
a single number what specific criteria
should be used
you might suggest student satisfaction
teaching quality graduate employment
rate or how can you forget the cost of
tuition
wrong wrong wrong and lol
what rankings do consider is the
proportion of international students
which brings us to the positive feedback
loop
each new international student increases
their school's ratio which in turn
boosts its overall ranking
meanwhile how do international students
choose schools
that's right rankings
around and around and around
at some point to reject international
students is to willfully forgo prestige
and therefore revenue
this irresistible self-perpetuating
cycle encourages schools to admit
students even with an inadequate grasp
of english setting them up to fail
schools that pursue this strategy tend
to have very large chinese student
populations which often results in
social bubbles on campus
after four years they may graduate with
few if any local friends despite coming
in large part for that exposure
now to put things in perspective the
international student ratio only
comprises five percent of the qs ranking
formula
but make no mistake their actual
contribution is many times larger
few americans pay the price of tuition
shown on google
those who attend college in their own
state pay only about half the sticker
price and even out of state tuition is
offset by financial aid
about the only students who do pay full
price are international students
and on top of that they pay additional
fees disproportionately live in student
dorms and buy university meal plans
with all that extra cash schools can buy
their way up the rankings attracting
even more students and so on
in 2008 baylor offered new students 1
000 a year in student aid to retake
their sats and score an extra 50 points
artificially boosting its numbers
qs even offers a paid consulting service
in a clear conflict of interest
in the best case this extra cash is
spent hiring more teachers increasing
its teacher-to-student ratio which
comprises 20 of the qs formula and
attracting researchers who boost the
school's academic citations another 20
percent
now you might argue that's how things
are supposed to work money affords
quality the rich get richer no surprise
there and there's no reason schools
should all be equal
but what does quality really mean
teacher-to-student ratios tell you how
small a school's classes are but not how
good the teaching students may wonder
why so many of their classes are capped
at 19 or 20 students
the reason is that us news counts the
number of classes with 20 or fewer
the result is that access to the best
professors is restricted in a world with
an infinite number of great teachers
smaller class sizes would always be
better but as anyone who's attended
college can tell you that's definitely
not the case
citations per faculty is an even worse
proxy for quality
the number of academic publications a
school produces has almost nothing to do
with the undergraduate experience
in fact more time spent on research
equals less emphasis on teaching
when folks reminisce about college they
mention things like the fun social
environment and maybe one or two
standout classes
what they don't tend to remember is
their school's number of academic
citations
silly as this sounds millions of
students inadvertently choose schools
based on this very criteria
yet just two percent of admissions
directors think ranking systems are
quote very effective at helping students
find the right school
all they really do is reward those
willing to play the game like
singapore's ntu who made massive leaps
in the ranking thanks to a sudden
coordinated burst of research
that's of course assuming the research
being cited is even good you can
probably think of a widely cited paper
linking vaccines to a certain
neurological disorder
now you might counter that students are
just holding it wrong misunderstanding
what rankings actually measure
research
but they aren't even good at measuring
that
a full 50 percent of the qs formula is
reputation
how does a school gain a reputation in
no small part rankings
in other words rankings measure
reputation and reputations are
determined by ranking
professor emmanuel orterica calls
rankings harvardometers suggesting they
merely measure how close a school is to
what we already assumed to be the best
any formula that didn't place harvard
near the top would have to go back to
the drawing board until it did
still somehow it gets worse
way worse
the way reputation is measured is in
part with online surveys in which
respondents are rewarded with free swag
u.s news has college presidents rate
hundreds of their competitors on a scale
of one to five in one study princeton's
business school was ranked in the top 10
despite not even existing
meanwhile according to researchers
rankings aren't even precise enough to
accurately distinguish between first and
tenth place
the problem is that we act as though
they can
in one egregious case administrators of
the university of malaya were fired
after it suddenly dropped 80 places in
the times ranking due only to a change
in definition
so why not group schools together to at
least avoid giving the false impression
of precision
because this volatility is a core part
of the ranking's business model it
produces an annual round of drama and
publicity
wow this school dropped 10 places and
this one gained 5 when nothing
effectively changed as far as students
are concerned
so
colleges can't be reduced to a single
number
even if they could this isn't how you do
it and even if it were you wouldn't add
all these different metrics together
producing a result that neither
accurately measures reputation quality
or research
but remember rankings are not just a
corporate parasite one can ignore
imagine if consumer reports had a total
monopoly on public information about
phones tvs or cars
apple and toyota would design their
products not based on what we actually
want but whatever arbitrary metrics
profit-seeking consumer reports decides
on
we've talked about schools that benefit
from this system but for every harvard
ntu and princeton a dozen more are held
totally captive against their will
ranking companies enforce compliance
with a threat either hand over the data
we demand or your rankings will suffer
that's no exaggeration us news for
instance assigns schools who refuse to
play the game below average scores
ultimately everyone suffers professors
are incentivized to farm citations to
keep their jobs students are deceived
international students totally exploited
and administrators encouraged to cheat
yet we all actively play the game
colleges whose very professors write
papers eviscerating the methodology of
rankings continue advertising their us
news ranking on pamphlets
even you watching this very video may
intellectually believe rankings are
pointless but will surely close this
window and continue acting otherwise
it's a kind of psychological pyramid
scheme
even if you don't believe in rankings
you'd be wise to act as though you do
because real or fake they really do mean
something to other people
to justify our crushing student loans
and because you'd be dumb not to
advertise the good school you attended
we recruit others perpetuating the
belief that rankings mean anything
but things may be about to change
remember at the heart of all this were
international students
just a few short years ago the rapid
growth of chinese students on u.s
campuses produced a mix of both ugly
racist anxiety and legitimate concerns
about academic freedom
schools had found a seemingly bottomless
source of income
to them it felt like an infinite money
glitch
and when every cast of the line is even
more fruitful than the last even the
most rational fishermen will struggle to
restrain themselves
how could they deliberately leave all
this free money on the table and besides
if they don't catch these fish someone
else will
thus they continue to depend more and
more on chinese international students
even while aware of the risk of relying
so heavily on one single market
today the concern is reversed
when national borders closed in the
spring of 2020 and restrictions extended
into summer universities began wondering
if they had just permanently lost a
critical component of their revenue
model
the decline in international students
doesn't look catastrophic
that is until you focus on the number of
new international students
existing students are likely to finish
their degrees no matter what and because
the decision to take the sat over the
cow cow for instance is made years in
advance in china schools still have a
few years of runway left
students who've already committed to
this path
the concern is that while most of the
world will return to normal the largest
and most lucrative source of students
china never will
because for them kovit is only one in an
already growing list of concerns about
studying or even living abroad
the chinese government increasingly
portrays the world beyond its borders as
a violent unwelcoming apocalyptic
wasteland seizing on every legitimately
tragic crime in order to tell a larger
story of state collapse
the number one criteria for choosing a
school is not teaching quality career
prospects or even cost of living
it's by far safety
and international students have never
felt less safe in america
what does it mean for higher education
that a central feature of their business
academic and incentive structure may be
permanently disrupted
that their largest source of revenue may
suddenly be gone forever
how will they compensate when this
wasteful inefficient system also becomes
financially insolvent
the truth is no one yet knows not even
they do
some argue the university model is in
decline and will soon be replaced with
mass online education
but schools still have one giant
advantage
anything can be learned online but only
schools can offer accountability
structure and guidance
that's also the premise behind fabulous
today's sponsor
fabulous is a habit forming and tracking
app backed by science
you don't need an app to meditate get
better sleep or be more productive but
most of us myself included need
motivation and accountability to do so
consistently
you pick the healthy habits and fabulous
will help you actually stick to them
what i like about the app is that it
adjusts to you they know that you'll
resist anything that feels like homework
so instead the app learns when and how
to remind and motivate you
i used to run seven days a week 52 weeks
a year but kinda accidentally took this
last year or so off i've been using
fabulous for over a month now and i'm
back to exercising three times a week
start building your ideal daily routine
the first 500 people who click the link
on screen now or in the description will
get 25 off fabulous premium